it's just for everyone i think uh
because uh we do hear uh about some of
the
confusion that are there with all the
resources that have been shared
so i just wanted uh all of us to go
through some of these resources and to
understand where to find
uh the the things that we discussed
today
so this is the pre-registration page
where we all started and
like many of you have pre-registered
here so in this page
uh we have a video overview and then we
have the session details
um along with that there's a form that
you have many of you have filled up and
then we send out the emails so uh
when you go through this page and
you would want to learn more about the
sessions so the second thing that i
would like to take you to is the program
syllabus and how we have planned the
live sessions and the resources that are
associated with it
so one of the exciting part of this
program is just uh
which also differentiates us from other
other similar
similar you know online programs is that
uh there are several
uh resources that are associated with
each of the programs so this is
the syllabus page and
sonatica if you can paste the link of
this page too
so that we can all browse through this
page so um
as as we go to this page this page
actually describes
the the curriculum that we have
developed and
also the resources that would be
associated
including the assignments the hands-on
sessions and what will be covered in the
hands-on sessions
and where would you learn about those
technologies and what all elia just said
about
you know getting started with uh with
big data getting started with
uh gene expression data getting started
with um
uh genomic data and then applying it for
for cancer problem and applying it for
infectious diseases
so there's a lot to learn and there is
so i mean i'm really
happy that we have all of you to get
together today
to showcase some of these that we have
put together for this program
so there's a video uh again which gives
an overview of what was covered so you
have already seen what was covered
so session wise when we go to the
when we will start which would be on
tuesday so we are going to start
next tuesday at uh
9 30 a.m cst i think it's 10 10 mcst
so yeah so in the first session we will
be covering about bioinformatics and
translational oncology research
so this would be the overview of uh
of the cancer problem as we were
discussing we will discuss about the
complexity
in the sense of how it is being
described in
a tissue organ and you know
cell cellular level and then the
molecular factors that
actually are associated with tumor
development growth and metastasis
then we will understand that the how how
genotypic and phenotypic
relationship uh can be identified
through
these clinical and molecular data types
and then we will go through the
uh the overview of the platform and what
we will be
doing throughout the course so this will
be on the on the
on the first session which will also be
available uh to all of you
and uh the the associated
online resources as i was telling you
that um
at we started off with uh the
learn site so let me go to the learn
site
this is the associated uh associated
courses that are available on the learn
site
so if you have not created a login for
yourself
so please do that this is the
link and let me show you how you can do
that it's very simple
and this is also for to uh to also for
those who would not
uh who are participants who would be
participants and also for those who
would think about joining later but
uh you know it's great to have you here
it's a free login
so you can just log in with your email
address or your
social media address so i'll just sign
in
so once i sign in um i'll come to the
home page
i'll just show you how to navigate
through this website
so once you come to the home page it
describes all of what we described
and discussed today as well as uh what
are different specialization that you
can opt for
so we have specializations in oncology
infectious diseases neuroscience
agriculture
and then the tbi info server and also
all of the things that we discussed our
associations
and then uh the interesting thing about
the syllabus is that we will in
start with introduction to
bioinformatics so let's go to our first
course
introduction to bioinformatics which
would be covered in the first session
so in the first session we would want to
learn uh we would all want to learn
about
where bioinformatics can be applied
especially in biomedical research
so all the areas that you might be
interested in you will be able to
navigate through this
and this uh this course also has a form
which let us
uh uh let let us uh know
more about you about your research
interest so this is a course that i
recommend you
all to take and it's a free course so
once you create your login here
your free login here you can start
taking this course uh
after your login is done and you have a
profile
so let me quickly show you what our
profile is profile looks like
so this is my academic profile i have a
image and i
have uh i've described myself so one of
the benefits of having a profile is that
you will be able to see your progress
how many courses you have finished how
many programs that you are enrolled
in and also like uh what are the as i
said that what are the courses that i'm
enrolled in i'm doing
and what are the programs i'm enrolled
in and i'm like interested in going
through
and then the certifications that i have
that i've gained from
uh taking the courses these courses or
completing the programs
so all of this you will gain and get
from this
profile once you just create a free
profile here and put some of the
information that would help us
learn more about you and also like uh
like also uh people who are interested
to collaborate with you
or people who are interested to hire you
for uh any
uh specific research work so all of that
is uh
actually are the components of having uh
the profile
so this i would really recommend you to
all of you to
create and at least go through the free
resources that are available with all of
the sessions
so as i said that the first session that
would be about introduction to
bioinformatics and introduction to
cancer the second session is more
technical where we dive into
uh genomics so uh in genomics we will
learn about next generation sequencing
we will learn about how we can
how we can analyze genomic data and find
out those
variants and those variations and those
mutations significant mutations
so again there is a bunch of courses
that explains genomics and uh
one of the benefits of doing this is not
just that you
would be able to learn from the very
beginning from the very basic
starting with the dna structure but also
you will have an option to work
and learn r and apply r or python
uh using our uh coding playground
tutorials
so here you i will show you another
demonstration
where you will able to also apply data
science techniques
so about genomics uh you will be also go
be able to go through
the hands-on sessions and the hands-on
sessions with
the star mark are the ones that are
available
to the participants and also to those
who would want to subscribe
for the asynchronous material so uh when
i click into this i'll get information
about how i can prepare my pipeline and
understand about the process of creating
a pipeline and
what are the components that are
involved so once you complete this is
like an achievement that i've gone
through this tutorial and
i have gone through this tutorial so uh
but not uh yet on the platform so
here you will also learn about the data
sets that are embedded in the
with the link that you will get so these
are all the benefits of uh
getting to the to the asynchronous
material and going through the tutorials
and that goes from you know basic
introduction
to building up variation variant
pipelines to do a phylogenetic analysis
and again uh go through multiple
sequence alignment
to see the variation and evolution of
genomes
so obviously there are so many
applications which i cannot list out uh
in this session however uh the second
session and the third session after the
second session learning about genomics
would be about transcriptomics data so
gene expression data
here also we will go through uh the an
overview of
how you uh i mean what is the
significance what is rna sequencing why
it is done
um its history and then about its
application that how do you do it and uh
like get
uh understanding about the quality of
the file
that are available and then how do you
pre-process the data
map it to the genome and going through
all that process
so we will be doing this on the t-band
for platform
so just let me quickly uh go to the
t-bind for platform
so sorry about this this is a different
pipeline
so this is the t-bar info platform uh
which we discussed
in this meeting and which is a really
amazing platform which is a very
comprehensive as well
describes all of the ngs data data types
and
uh shows us uh very elaborated
methods and pipelines to uh you know
analyze this sort of data
so uh this is a typical pipeline this is
how it looks
and uh one of the best part of this is
that
it's uh the entire platform is very uh
you know
friendly because it describes all of the
processes all of the data types
that are there and uh what are the
applications that we can do with this
so when we go into this section this is
about transcriptomics and i was
discussing
session about the transcriptomics so
here
uh we will be going through the
uh the example data sets that we have
compiled for you and learn from
so this is a pipeline which has already
uh inbuilt data sets which are put
together
and you will be learning about those
data sets in the session and then we
will be going through
the pipeline together building a
pipeline how how this
you know format makes sense why these uh
these are placed in this manner so the
flow is that that these algorithms are
placed in
i know many of you are already aware of
this but for those who are not
are in a logical manner put together in
a logical manner
where we start from pre-processing the
data to then error connect correction
then maybe mapping it to the genome or
you know
uh doing isoform construction or doing
uh mapping it to the transcriptome
or doing differential gene expression so
there are several experiments
i mean you can build from different
paths that you can take
to analyze your data so in this uh
in this session we will be learning
about the breast cancer
sample cell lines that we discussed and
the publication that is associated with
the session
so i think i can i can go about it a
little bit more but
i i think we don't have that much time
but coming to the
part where we will be discussing about
uh the application
and there was a question about
classification and clustering
in the chat i think um it is something
that
also i would love to talk more and more
about but we already have a session
described uh for this where we will be
going through machine learning
and in this we will be uh applying gene
expression data
and finding patterns from the gene
expression data so
uh in this process we will be applying
um
machine learning methods using the tb
info server obviously
so we have those very well defined in
these sections of data mining so you
will be able to
do clustering and pca and also
if network but yeah you can start with
all of these methods
or when you start with uh the program
and also like uh to those who are
joining uh i think it's great to start
with the coursework and get a glimpse of
uh the sessions before actually the
start of the program
so now i would also want to tell you
more about a little bit of machine
learning and biomedical data
and data science uh so how what is the
data science aspect
so um sorry
let's go back to the courses
and let me search for data science
so we have a lot of data science courses
and
one of the example i would want to show
you is that introduction to data science
for r so here we have a lot of tutorials
uh that you will be able to go through
and it's relevant to the session
uh so we will be going through some of
the visualization
techniques how would you do pca and com
using our code so as you as i as i said
that um our studio is uh
is available here on the browser
so you can actually learn about the
problem here
and then learn about the data that is
available
and then the the
the commands where it is described what
it
it
explains like what data set that we are
taking what kind of uh
uh what kind of uh step that we are
doing
so here uh once you learn about these
steps
and learn about what will be done with
the data
you will have an opportunity to do it do
it yourself
so it's a big tutorial
so learning about all these techniques
uh going through the assignments and
you'll be able to run it yourself so
this is a code block
where this you can run the scripts by
learning
about the scripts and then actually
doing it yourself and
getting results so for the data sets
that uh
maybe our researchers are working on our
research fellows are working on
they're utilizing these these tools to
come up with uh
with images and for presentations and
publications etc so this was about
that and then the fifth session is about
oncology where we will be learning about
the data sorry oncology data sources so
it's more about the data
repositories so we will be going to ncbi
we will be looking at the data sets that
are available there learning from them
uh taking some of them as examples and
understanding how
they connect i mean how do you annotate
your results better
so how do you annotate your mutations
how do you annotate
what in information that you're getting
out of the machine learning
after the machine learning analysis so
this is the first phase
after the first phase second phase is
all about infectious disease problems
in this we will be learning about viral
genomes
and host transcriptomes so we have
also virology sections that will be
utilized in this program
so so going back to that
so here we will have examples projects
in this style
from this part you will start working on
projects you will have an opportunity to
start working on projects
so these projects are asynchronous
projects that you can take any time
and you will have an opportunity to work
them through
when you have uh uh availability
and uh these are like very descriptive
projects that describes
uh yeah i mean these are some of the
data sets that
are described by publications and uh we
have put together how do you analyze and
uh understand from what the authors have
described
so uh these are some of the example
projects
and then we will learn about uh genomic
uh
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogeny and we have another few
projects like kuvin19 and ebola
so these are again about the mutations
and uh how
how kobe 19 or i mean this is from a
paper
uh that describes the proximal origin of
saskof2 it was published in nature
medicine 2020
um so yeah you will learn about go
this you can learn from this project as
well along with the session
so these are the live sessions that we
will be covering and along with that
there are always
asynchronous material available for you
to take
throughout the week and then we will go
through project examples
where we will learn how to compare uh
and i mean these are different
biological questions that we are asking
from the data
so that you get an experience of how can
you ask your question
from your research so again like after
learning about all of this
uh the last part of the session
the 10th session is about host pathogen
interaction
so here we will learn and connect uh
some of the aspects of
our omics data to structure and uh you
know finding those
key mutations and understanding those
and
then the effect of what it caused for
the
function of the protein so this is what
is planned for this
precision medicine program and i hope
that
i've been able to describe this well
to all of you and i'll be happy to
answer any questions that you have
and also i wanted to add that signing up
on the learn
that is learn.omicslogic.com would get
you the automatic
access of the t by info server as well
which dr mohay just shared
and uh yes so we also share i
i will be mailing you all the details
which were
uh discussed in the session and also
would give you the links and how you can
proceed further with your
submission right so thank you sonalika i
just wanted to add a couple of things so
we also have a slack channel and i
forgot to mention about the program uh
part
so yeah when you go to learn and when
you do this
login you'll be able to go to this tab
programs
so in programs we have all the programs
listed out that are upcoming or have
been ongoing
so you will find precision medicine here
and to register for this program
uh with live sessions and everything not
just the asynchronous material
you have to start your application so
using this link
and once you start your application you
can select different options
so these options involve all the cloud
access so there are five terabyte of
space that would be allocated
uh and you will be able to run the cloud
pipelines and then the coding sessions
all of this is included in this in this
in this patch
package and here uh you will be also
able to apply some of the discount codes
or
some of the fee waivers that have been
provided by sunalika
and also for lower income countries we
have a scholarship option
that is also available and i would like
to request those who are applying for
scholarship to do it
as soon as possible because we are going
to start the program
on tuesday so we can process your
application by
monday so i would also request sonalika
to share the
scholarship scholarship link so there
are different access
levels so different licenses another
license is about the intermediate step
step where you would want to have an
additional one-on-one mentor support
where you would want to go through some
of the materials along with the mentor
ask your research question so even in
this entire program and even in the
webinars that we do
uh it would be really nice to discuss
your research question but yeah
obviously
there's a limitation of time but when
you are in one of the programs then it
would be
uh it would give us like a lot of time
for uh you
with you to discuss your research and
work on your idea
and if we can utilize these resources to
be able to come up with the research
outcome
so the research part uh is also being in
this advanced license so it gets you to
work on
your own project an additional month of
cloud access so this is that one's
license and then obviously there you
will have access to a lot of courses and
then once you go into the sessions and
like register for the program
you will be able to see a different
interface and so i'll take you there but
you will also be able to come up and
it will also be able to get your
certificate as i showed you earlier
so this is the registration part and
along with this
uh now let's let me show you i'm not
registered for this program so i would
just want to show you
another program and the interface so
once you're registered this is the
interface that you get
so you will get uh the courses that
you're doing and all of that and you can
uh ask for a q a or you can ask for a
mentor session
and then you'll get your certificates
here and uh when the sessions are
ongoing you will find the session videos
here
so the recording video recording you
will get into when you
get uh registered and then you will have
access to an interface like this
and then you will be able to get the
session recordings
into this interface so that you wouldn't
have to you know go anywhere it's just
in
same place where you will find all the
details so also the same thing
with for the zoom link for the next
session you will be able to find the
zoom link as well so this is another
program that is ongoing
for our partners in louisiana so it's a
program with lvrn network
so i think yeah and that's it that i
wanted